Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcasts. And
I'm just checking in on you.
Checking into something like voices
Juncker just did six shows up in San Jose
Cruz.
I've been for the Houston Astros.
That was one of my favorite players. Yeah,
my voice is going to be a little tight.
It's give me a little rough, you know. Um,
I did six shows up there to
Monday to Tuesday to Wednesday,
just like when I was in Phoenix to
Monday to Tuesday to fucking Wednesday.
I'm putting together my new a hour and
I really felt by Wednesday of this week
it had gotten to the point where we're
starting to do, starting to take shape.
And I was very happy and I want to
thank everybody who came out, you know,
on school nights.
I know you guys all have to work
unless you hit the fucking lottery.
I assumed all he had to
go to work the next day.
So I want to thank everyone in San
Jose who came out to go see me.
And, um, thank you for sitting through the
new jokes. I had a great time up there,
worked with Dean del Ray. Fucking
crushed it, crushed it all fucking week.
Um, had a great time
working with them, you know,
and dean like this is the funny thing
about Dean when I worked with Dean Dean,
you know, he doesn't party or anything
like that. He's done all of that shit.
So He's over it. So then, you know,
I'm, I'm a fucking codependent jackass,
you know what I mean? So I mean, to a
point someone's doing coke and heroin,
I'm like, Hey, I'm going to bed. Okay. Um,
but it's when it comes to the booze
was smoking cigars, right. That's why,
you know,
me and all my friends,
I mean we're all codepen guys and we just
fucking feed off of each other and it
becomes fucking, you know, animal
house. But, um, so he, he's,
he doesn't do that. Right. So
my eyes can be great, you know,
I'm not going to spend any extra
money. Busan, no extra calories.
I was hitting the gym, was
doing everything great. But a,
the thing about dean is he has
impeccable taste and shit that I like old
instruments,
old cars.
He was showing me this guy that fucking
read does these Porsche nine 11 out here
that would just fucking insane,
insane.
Like he has all like, you
know, not a lot of stuff,
but he has all top of the line shits.
I was joking with them, I was like,
all the money that I'm going to fucking
not blow in a bar after my show.
I'm then going to spend 10 times more
that on fucking Ebay after I get done
talking to you. But um,
anyways, he murdered it all
week. We had such a great time.
And um, San Jose Improv, that's one of
my favorite places because it's really,
it's really, it's a
small theater, you know,
from the turn of the last century at the,
believe it was built in the 1890s burned
down back when Shit used to burn down
all the time because it was made
out of fucking wood, you know,
as opposed to what now bill, I don't know.
We didn't, they didn't have sprinklers.
That's what it was.
When a houses man out of plastic bill,
you know, you've been out in
Hollywood so long, you plastic phony,
you think everything's made out of
well then they would melt, right?
Plastic is it flammable but just cowers.
You know what I mean?
Like your friend who says,
I got your back, I'm not
going to fucking rat you out.
And then all of a sudden the teacher
comes walking in and he goes,
you always had this idea. That's
what plastic is. You know, why?
Cause it's manmade. Um, anyway,
so it burned down and then they rebuilt
it in the early 19 hundreds and everyone
from like Harry Houdini, Charlie Chaplin,
they always bring up those two guys.
Nobody ever says a, you know, fatty
Arbuckle played here. Nobody gives a shit.
Right. I love that name. Fatty Arbuckle.
You know, that's back when you just,
you said what the person was for better
for worse. You know what I mean? You know,
you could just say fatty Arbuckle. Why?
Cause cause he's a fat fuck. You know?
Sure. You had a first name. Nobody knows
what it is, but people go, you know,
back then it was great, you
know, you fucking, yeah,
but then people also walk around, drop
for the fucking end work. You know,
like they'll ask saying pass the sugar.
But the upside to that was you,
you knew who thought what as opposed to
now wherever he goes, African American,
homosexual, vericut, Japanese where
cause and you have no idea who's what.
Everybody's walking around and you feel
like you're in the fucking invasion of
the body snatchers. Who's
thinking what? Right.
Everybody's reading from the same book.
It's not a good God damn thing.
I don't even know what the fuck
I'm talking about right now. Um,
I literally got off,
got on the earliest flight.
I'm doing this thing now
because I want to run home,
rush home and see my daughter,
my daughter.
But I get home cause I take the earliest
flight out and I'm fucking exhausted.
Then I have to go to sleep.
So I'm sucks. I came home,
I think she has to remember who I am
just three days away, three days away.
Like as far as what percentage of her
life she was looking at me like making
this face like, who the fuck
is this guy? She didn't cry.
Thank God that would've broke my heart.
But you know,
it took me like 20 minutes to
get a smile out of her. Um,
what else am I going to do? Want to
get again, nine to five job, you know,
drive the fucking
Chevy cavalier like, but what the fuck
a lot of you guys are doing right now,
stuck in traffic. I know you don't
want to do that, right? You got dream.
Let me tell you something.
You got to,
you're going to find that dream and you
got to go after it. I'm kidding. Um,
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
You know,
there's a lot of times I look at somebody
who's sitting in a cubicle and that
will be great. I do, I just
fucking sit there. I just, I,
I go from here to right fucking there,
right?
I just send my chair spins
from this to here. Right?
That's my range of fucking motion.
I get my job done and I go home and you
know something at this country company
goes under, I don't give a fuck. I've
to just go to another one eight on me.
You know that rent to own rental leaf.
That's how you do it anyways.
Uh, what's going on in my world?
Other than that, I'm excited.
Finally excited about my new hour.
Finally,
finally,
af had some fucking jokes.
I'm the fucking boss, the Bro and
still, they gotta win tonight.
They play in fucking Tampa Bay.
Lightening Down there in Florida.
Dude. I know, like fucking 12 people
already fucking move down there.
You know what I mean? It's
fucking crazy. It's like,
what are you fucking 80
can't take the wind anymore.
You're going to lose your edge.
Dope.
Yeah,
Dude. I went down there.
I, I visit fucking,
I've visited fucking whatever.
Fucking Bobby McAfee dude.
He's always walking around in shorts.
Fucking flip flops,
sitting down by a dark, hanging
out with all these fucking Weirdos.
Just like, don't you know, look at
you. You're all fucking tanned up.
You know it's good, but do you, you got
to come back to, you got to go to donkeys.
Yeah.
Get to lodge with extra sugar,
um,
broads in the middle of a
three game fucking slide.
We lost Edmonton and then
we went over Edmonton,
Alberta and then we went to Toronto,
Ontario and we fucking lost there.
And then we went to Ottawa,
the capital, the capital,
ladies and gentlemen of
Canada. I was actually, that's,
I was trying to remember
all the provinces,
the provinces and territories is 10
provinces and three territories up there.
And I could never fucking remember him
cause most of them begin with n whatever
other than enough of them do Nova Scotia,
New Brunswick.
Then there's something in
Labrador retriever or some shit.
Yeah.
What the fuck is it? New
Brunswick, Nova Scotia,
Newfoundland and Labrador. Prince
Edward Island. And the rest easy.
You just go on across according to fucking
hockey teams, the Quebec Nordiques,
well Toronto may police spent
at the Ontario my beliefs
and then at the man told
Manitoba fucking jets the Winnipeg jets,
right.
Saskatchewan, Alberta, British
Columbia. Then you go up top,
you've got the northwest territory,
you got Yukon,
and then the other one like
fucking begins with an n.
It sounds like an Italian word,
but it isn't like, forget about it.
The fuck is that thing called. This
has to be in the history of podcasting.
The most boring thing anybody's
ever brought up. Canadian.
Come on. Yukon, Wikipedia,
Canadian territory door,
uh,
terror tour territories.
The fuck is it called?
It's something Italian provinces
and territories of Canada.
Please take out your geography books.
The fuck is it called?
Oh yeah. Yeah. None. None of us.
Oh no, that's not, doesn't sound
Italian. Hey, we'll have none of that.
Okay.
Knock it off. No, none of
that. None of that would work.
Fuck off. I'm I, I got most of them. I
got most of them. All right, so anyways,
the Bruins are playing Tampa Bay
tonight. We need a wind. You know,
we just fucking beat Edmonton.
We've just want one of those fucking gays.
We had little breathing room, a little
breathe in Roman. Now, we don't,
now it's just like, you know, Joe Barton,
Dick taught me, talked me off the ledge,
she goes, you know, they will fucking
tired. They had back to back games.
Don't fucking hit the
panic panic button yet.
But then we lost again to fucking Ottawa.
Okay.
So I'm gonna listen to Joe Barton it
cause he knows way more about hockey than
I'll ever fucking know.
But if they lose tonight.
Yeah.
So we're looking at me possibly three
years in a row of being in the playoffs
with two weeks to go in March and then
sitting at home, you know, which uh,
Barney gets told me that's the worst
fucking thing to just miss the playoffs.
Okay. Cause you don't get any playoff
money and you don't get a good draft pick.
But who knows? Maybe somebody
will miss somebody good. I mean,
that's how we got Tom Brady.
Right?
Everybody just fucking was
looking at him like, you know,
he's got a nice dimple in his
chin. But other than that, I dunno.
You can see why they passed a bike and
see why they passed it by when he fucking
dove after you threw that pick six,
you know, and the Superbowl this year.
Just look that up.
Him diving to tackle and just look
at how unathletic he looks, you know,
anytime anybody ever says like fucking
out of fucked it all these teams way to
the what? What was he, the fourth round?
Six round. How did they miss this guy?
Just show that video and just say,
imagine that running the 40 yard dash.
You know what Tom Brady is?
He's a fucking sleep.
That's what he is.
He showed up looking like a Volvo station
wagon and they didn't realize what was
under the hood. You know what
it was? It was a four 54,
454 cubic kids.
She's a fucking hat.
I'm sorry. Alright. Plowing ahead. Um,
other sports talk Formula One starts on
this Sunday if you want to get into it
like I did last year and last year,
the Mercedes Benz team with Lewis Hamilton
and Nico Rosberg the sense retired
Nico Rosberg cause he wanted to hang out
with his daughter, which I didn't fuck.
Or his kid,
which I didn't understand until I came
home after three days in San Jose.
And my own daughter's looking at
me like, uh, it's just a driver.
Who the hell is this guy? Um, who knows?
I always, I always want to blame the
woman, you know, that his wife was like,
it's really dangerous. I mean,
you won the championship. I mean,
this whole thing with Louis,
it's just, it's, it's you, it's,
you talk about it all the time. We can't
even sit down for a meal. I get it.
You think he's a cunt, but
you know, I just, what about,
did you just be here with me?
Yeah.
You know, that's the danger of
being with the wrong woman. You,
you end up stepping out of a formula
one car and just say, hey, you know,
one or maybe he's smart.
Maybe he's just like that guy who plays
blackjack and goes up early and just
says, Hey, you know what? Fuck this.
I'm going back to the room taking my
money and I'm going back to the fucking
room.
I have no idea.
I don't even understand this God
damn sport to be honest with you.
I still don't what happened to the
steering wheel and why it looks like a
fucking game boy now.
And how the fuck sitting there
like driving that Goddamn fast.
You have time to take your hand off the
wheel and fucking search for that button
to pick a new, uh, a new suspension.
Like you're in a Tesla with your friend
driving up fucking route to, hey,
you want me to put it in an insane
fucking mode? Whatever the hell it is,
except they're doing this shit
at 200 miles an hour. By the way,
I went by a Tesla dealership
when I was up in, uh,
San Jose and, um, they have, uh,
they're the new one up there, you
know, that it had, it had, you know,
the original ones just had the
motor, um, for the rear wheels.
Now they got one for the front and
the back. And evidently it goes,
we need to get the top of the
line, the best one, right. It's,
it's limited with them. It's just
like what, what gives it, um,
makes it worth more money is the amount
of fucking electrical power you have.
It's all a bit,
cause everything other than that,
I think they're pretty much all the same.
And if you get the top of the line one,
um, it goes zero to 60 in 2.5
seconds. That's like a fucking,
that's motorcycles level speed.
MMM.
And it's a four door. Looks like a
fucking Nissan Maxima. Not even know.
It doesn't look like that.
It looks like maybe like a Toyota super
fucked in Nissan masks at maximum.
One of those late,
mmm.
Late eighties. Once. Um, was
it the super, the Celica?
I can't fucking remember.
All I know is,
you know what car I would love to fucking
own for like a year is one of those
like a 71 or 72 like Datsun five 10.
Just have the whole fucking thing redone.
Um, I, I gotta be honest with you.
I you're, I'm hard pressed
to find a fucking car that I,
that I can't see that would be fun
to drive. You know what I mean?
So there's so many fucking great
cars out there. The only ones I, I,
I'm not really interested in is all
the American muscle cars at this point
because they're just fucking everywhere.
Everybody has one.
Every time you put on Mika and we've
got some more power power coming up and
it's the same guy comes a coup de,
it comes a fucking Amie.
This hemi that it comes to Shelby
here comes to fucking, you know,
the day I only made a couple of
these Camaro's so 19 fucking 69,
you know, this is a
Mustang boss. It's there.
They're all fighting over the same
fucking three models. Meanwhile,
is all these other fucking
cool as cars out there. Um,
I'm actually glad that the baby boomers
are still infatuate that cause it keeps
the prices down of the shit that I like.
Um,
yeah, I'm a fucking Weirdo dude. I like
those. Ford does Ford vans from the 60s.
You know, it's just a
shame that, you know,
a couple of fucking serial killers that
dressed up like clowns drove around in
vans. They really ruined the name of
them. But what did the upside of that?
The upside of pedophilia
is if you're into vans,
you can get one for really cheap.
The trade off is you can never grow
a mustache for the rest of your life.
That's it. Um, anyway,
so for Formula One starts this Sunday
in Australia and last year then Mercedes
Benz teams where the a was with
um, Mercedes van team, sorry,
was the team to beat in this year.
Evidently the Ferrari's are, uh,
are looking like they're going
to be really strong and a,
I guess everybody's rooting for who is it?
Who the fuck is the Australian driver?
Therefore, the, uh, the red bull
team, he's coming down there.
What the fuck's his name?
What's his name? Uh,
Daniel. Ricardo. Hello.
Okay.
You're getting ready to leave.
Does she still remember who I am?
She was looking at me like, who the
hell is this guy? All right sweetie.
Go ahead at that though.
Huh? I ain't get a smile.
Can I get a, she's staring at
the microphone. I liked that.
How are you going to get in
Showbiz? No, no. Treat me like food.
Yeah, I think she's kind of over me.
Let me hang with it for like two,
three hours today. Get that bond
back. Get the bond back. Yeah.
Can you see by data?
She's just staring at it.
She'd read a look at a pillow then
me. Hey Buddy. You remember me?
Look at me. Who Do you think
paid for that? Onesy that was me.
Nothing. She's looking
down. She's got no interest.
Unbelievable. That's the kind of charisma
I have. All right. You guys go have fun.
Okay. Bye. I'll see you. Bye everybody
on the clock and ass. All right,
bye. See you later. To my two ways. Um,
all right. So, um, she
didn't look at me once. Um,
whenever I understand. Okay. It's
a brand new brain still working.
She's putting together her shit. The way
I'm putting together my act. You got,
or she already doesn't like me, but you
know, I really can't blame them. Um,
Daniel Ricardo is the guy,
but here's the thing about him.
Everybody in Australia claims the guy.
All right,
which is bullshit I think because he
didn't move to fucking Australia till he
was seven. He came from
Sicily. Alright. I bet.
I bet he's got some stories about
everybody teasing them with this fucking
accent when he first showed up to
Australia, but he's got some stories.
Any Sicilian, so you know, you
know, he never forgets whatever.
Australia will like your claim them maybe
you got kicked out like all those Brits
incentive, that fucking
land. Who knows. But, um,
so everybody's going to be pulling for
him. I can't fucking wait. I can't,
I can't believe how excited I am for
this shit that I finally stuck it through
one of those whole seasons
and I'm totally into it.
So I'm probably borne a lot
of you, but um, who knows.
All right, let's get to the,
let's get system all bullshit here.
Um,
did I already talk about everything?
Oh,
you know what else I did
when I was up there? Um, the
Improv up, they have found a,
a, a drum room for me and on two
days I got to play for two hours,
both fucking days.
I snuck four hours in.
That's what I do when I'm on the road
cause I can't really play drums, you know,
as much as I like, which is basically
an hour to two hours every fucking day.
I can't do that anymore.
Now I get out, you know,
a couple a couple of
days a week if I'm lucky,
but I got the whole practice pad
kit and all that shit here. So, um,
I got to go out and do that shit.
See how awful my playing is now. It was
really fucking depressing, you know,
but it was still a good time.
Um, all right, here we go.
Let's, let's read a little,
Oh,
you know what?
I have announcements I have to do if I
sound like I'm all over the place cause I
got like two hours.
Fucking sleep flight was at like 6:50 AM,
you know, and I, I never,
I usually don't do a podcast when I flew
the same fucking day. So. All right.
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh,
I have to remind the listeners
about Deanna Adler's,
Steven Adler's mom.
Um,
I interviewed her with Steven
Adler and um, Jamie Adler,
um, that was posted yesterday.
Please listen to it. And um,
Steven's mother,
mother is going to be at Barnes and
noble doing a book signing a week from
yesterday.
So that will be the 29th,
March 29th. She's going to be there. Let
me make, let me double check on them.
Make sure I don't fuck that up.
That would be a bad thing.
That would defeat the purpose of them
coming on here. All right. Where am I?
Where am I? Um, yeah,
the 29th at 7:00 PM at the growth
on Fairfax here in Los Angeles.
Um, she's gonna be at
the, uh, at the fucking,
at the God damn mall down there where they
used to have two stadiums, by the way.
We used to have a football stadium down
there and they used to have a baseball
state and we have you ever watched those
old school black and white home run
derbies and you wonder where they are.
I always thought they were liking like
the Washington senators, the original,
you know, Washington Senators Ballpark,
but they were actually out here in la,
which makes sense because it's
a fucking TV show anyways,
now it's a CBS slot and where
all that shit stood, you know,
they knocked it all down and then they
did like 9 million episodes of the prices.
Right. So you know what the
world moves ahead. All right.
In don't China, sorry. Just blew out
your ear. Drums, Indochina, everybody.
Chino.
Talk about how um,
a made to measure suit fits compared
to a generic off the rack suit.
And now every man looks better in a suit.
Hey,
why don't you fucking write
something and I'll, I'll read that.
I gotta sit here and riff.
You know,
they used to do that to comedians way back
in the day. They probably still do it.
We used to go on for commercial auditions
and you'd show up and then you know,
there's no coffee, there's no coffee.
They just want to see personality.
And then you'd go in there and you hold
up the product and you'd sit there,
riff and all this shit. And then
they would just steal all your jokes.
They wouldn't hire you.
And then they'd write the copy.
Well I think I told this story,
Patrice fucking called them out on it.
That's right.
I think I told this actually recently.
200 I'm standing there it goes.
He just walked in with like a can of coke
and just stared all three of them down.
Just so what?
What is this horse shit?
They all imploded and told them exactly
what the fuck they were doing. All right.
Do I really need the riff about this?
Okay. Do you know, unless you're,
unless you're fucking the exact same
measurements of a mannequin, you know,
you're not, something's going gonna look
fucked up. He just not gonna look right.
Okay. If you have a suit that's
fucking tailor made to your body,
obviously you have a by a
talk for your car. You know,
if you buy the one for your model,
your model car,
it fits like a glove as opposed
to just getting some generic one.
It's a little gust of wind
and it blows right off.
Do you want your suit pants to come
flying off and then you Dick's peeking out
of your boxers at the Christmas party
or do you want to fit suit? Well,
thank God for Indo Chino and dope child,
whatever the fuck they are,
they making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit and an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds
of top quality fat. Are
there hundreds of fabrics?
How many are there? It's like
cotton silk and ray on in my world.
The fuck else is there?
Plastic leather.
Yeah, that's it. I thought there was
less fabrics and there was fucking banks.
Um,
that individual banks and mean like
chase wells Fargo. That's what the fuck.
Hey Bill, why don't you just read the
copy? All right, fucking relax. All right.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work, a wedding,
or another special occasion,
whether you're a defendant.
Yeah.
What are you running for office?
What did he comment at town?
Are you going to sell all the fucking
rubes their instruments that don't exist?
Indochino has a suited up as suited up
hundreds of thousands of men and are now
the largest made to measure men's wear
brand in the world. Here's how it works.
Visited show showroom or shop online at
[inaudible] dot com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from the pills
to pleats to jacket linings in more.
Place your order and wait for it
to arrive in just a few weeks.
This week my listeners can get any
premium suit for only 389 bucks,
three to anything I boxes a sport coat.
Does that come with pants
and into china.com? Um,
when you had to burn a checkout,
that's 50 off the regular price for a
made to measure premium suit plus shipping
is for free though to get a fucking,
you know, accustomed suit, you know,
made to measure for only 389
bucks is pretty fucking good.
How do you spell Indochina?
I N D O C H.
I n O.
I n d o c H.
I n o.com.
Promocode birth for any premium suit
for just $389 and free fucking shipping.
All right. How many more do
we have? These fucking things.
The Black Tux, everybody.
The black, the black,
the black tops.
Everybody looking great for a wedding
or a special event has never been easier
with the black tux.com with a high quality
rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to
your doorstep,
the Black Tux is giving guys a
new way to rent and get this,
get a lot of this everybody,
the black Tux offers free home.
Try on so you can see the fit.
I always pictured when you tried it on
some old guy standing on your front porch
looking through the screen door,
you know it was old man clothes
and around his fucking, you know,
with his tape measure
around his neck or whatever.
Fuck he calling now to take measure
one to the tape measure for people.
Whenever you call that thing the best
part, it's completely done online.
No trips to the tuck shop required. The
black deep black Tux like the Ohio state,
the Black tux.com lets you create your
look or choose from tons of styles,
selected outfits starting at just $95.
These suits have a modern fit and are
made from a fire from fine Italian wool.
Oh there's another fabric,
cotton silk leather.
Raytheon will five down 95 to go the
highest quality on the rental market.
And if you have any questions or issues,
their expert customer care team has
your back every fucking step of the way.
And after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event.
That's a full two weeks to try it
on and make sure everything fits.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a
free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways. How easy
is that to get $20 off your purchase?
Visit the Black
tux.com/burr that's the black
tux.com/bird for $20 off your purchase
are going. Hey, I got to get
a glass of water. Hold on a
second. All right, I'm back.
I'm back. I apologize if he can hear
construction in the background. It's not.
It's not my house. Thank fucking
God. It's the house next door.
But you know the houses are all so close
together on here for whatever fucking
reason I'm probably gives us 7
billion people live out here, right?
Distilled genes, everybody. Great jeans.
Oh, they don't have to be complicated. No,
I can't find the buttons.
If you're not into stitching,
diamonds are embedded studs. You're
not alone. Distilled, pronounced,
distilled offers luxury grade
denim at an affordable price.
Jeans that would normally cost you
hundreds to still just has for fucking 75
bucks that utilize the same fabrics,
factories and wash houses as the
best known brands and designers.
So the same fucking poor bastards are
washing all these genes while skipping the
markups in the middleman,
the result, pure,
unadulterated denim without
the rental runaround.
Just go to distill.com spelled d e s
t l d.com and see where the minimalist
design meets maximum comfort. Oh,
these things feel great on your bulls.
They guarantee the fit.
They'll ship them to you for free and
you can give free returns until you find
the perfect pair.
I,
they actually sent me a pair of these
things are fucking great. That's great,
and yet you don't have to go to the mall.
Fucking wonderful.
There's still has been featured in Forbes
times and tech crunch as well as on
denim clad celebrities in Gq and vogue
distilled is the only place in the US.
You can get this quality of denim
for this price point. You can,
you can find their amazing selection of
outerwear, leather jackets, tee shirts,
and more using the same principles of the
high grade materials at low and costs.
Distilled is your answer.
To elevate your style,
just go to [inaudible] dot com slash
pro right now to get 10% off your first
pair, d, s t l d.com/. Bar. All right.
Legal Zoom,
mercifully the last one.
MMM.
Oh Shit. It's national small
business month. It always is.
And legal zoom.com.
You know something that national small
business month is like when you have some
shithole store that
always has that sign up,
but that they're going out of business
going out of business and they're in
business for like another
10 years. Um, anyways,
national small business
month@legalzoom.com is,
it's here and timing couldn't be better.
Proven rates for business loans are up.
Oh Great.
And so is computer consumer confidence,
but it takes a lot more than a good
timing to launch a successful business.
That's why legal zoom created
a free business startup kit.
Part of being an entrepreneur is
utilizing the right resources to help you
succeed. You can't be an
expert at everything, so go to
legalzoom.com/startup today and
download your free startup kit.
You'll get educated age,
educational ebooks and legal
zoom discounts to save money,
setting up your business.
Plus you can save thousands of dollars
Mucho Dinero through legal zooms
partners.
Um,
what?
Plus you can save thousands of dollars
through legal zooms partner offers to
help with financing,
marketing,
and day to day operations things you'll
need to run a successful business.
Did I write that sentence?
I could spend 20 minutes trying
to break that fucking thing down.
Trying to figure is that a fragment? Is
that a run on? There's no obligation.
April everybody. Just a lot of great
resources. Legal isn't a law firm.
It's not them.
Why would you think that?
Just because it says
legal in their name right?
But they're dedicated to make life
easier for the business owners.
Whether you're thinking of starting a
business already, run one, go to legal,
zoom.com/startup during national small
business month to take advantage of your
free business startup kit.
That's legal zoom.com/startup
oh guess what?
I wanted to thank somebody,
somebody on Twitter send me a,
somebody uploaded an entire Boston
Bruins versus the Chicago Blackhawks from
1974 and it's the Bruins feed.
So it's Fred Cusak doing the game.
Spoiler alert,
the Chicago Blackhawks win the face off.
They win the draw.
It goes back to Stan Mikita who
shoots it down to the Bruins and,
and it's then picked up by Bobby your
and it's, it's the whole fucking game.
I just sat there and it's a great,
great quality.
I hope nobody goes into fucking
takes it down. It's unbelievable.
If you just want to check it out,
like um,
the first thing I always noticed aside
from no helmets is like how small the
goalies are. It's like the one of
these guys scored like a fucking,
everybody was scoring 50 goals by
so many people scored 50 back then.
These guys barely took up. Like it looks
like a third of the net standup goalies.
You know, they played goalie, they look,
they look like they're in the Rockettes.
Cats just fucking kick their legs
out and shit. But it's, it's um,
I'll you know, I'll actually, I'll
maybe I'll put a link to it, um,
from the podcast and podcast or at
the MMP. Is that what the Twitter is?
I have no fucking idea. Um,
anyways, that's the, uh,
that's the podcast here for this Thursday.
I got something I got to go do.
I apologize. I know it was a
little scatterbrained here,
but however you can listen to some nice
music and then listen to a podcast,
um, from, I don't know when, I don't
know when it's going to be. It's from,
from yesteryear. When I was a little bit
younger, my brain wasn't as scattered.
Brad, it's always been scatterbrained.
Whose kid too? All right,
please enjoy the next half
of the podcast and I'm,
have a nice weekend.
You'd cuts.
Hey,
what's going on?
And this is the Monday morning
podcast for March 25th, 2009
a fucking podcast is to start to
feel like groundhog day for me.
I'm going to be a little grumpy, a little
extra grumpy this week because, uh,
I don't what happened. I uh,
well I do know what happened. Um,
I went out drinking last night and I
stayed out until about two in the morning
and,
uh,
I was driving home and I saw coyote and
I slowed down and for some reason felt
the need to yell at it, you know,
just to see what it would do.
Because according to Black Comedians,
that's what white people do around wild
animals. And Damn, I am the stereotype.
If Dad was a black mother fucker,
shit,
he kept driving down
the mother fucking room.
Why person be pulling over? Go over
there. What the fuck are you doing? Huh?
You want to bite me in the ass?
That's literally what the fuck I did.
I was a hacky def jam bet and those
were two of the worst impressions of two
races you're ever gonna hear. Um, but go
fuck yourself. I'm still in my pajamas.
You wear pajamas bill. Um,
when it's cold in my apartment,
I do still comfortable with my sexuality.
Um,
let me tell you something.
If you wear pajamas as a man
and you don't have a child,
you're just, you're a fucking, I don't
know what, but you're not something,
I want to be around these Pajama bottoms
in my way of saying that I hate myself.
Oh, Bill, why would you
say that? Um, anyways, yes.
So I just pulled over and I started
yelling at this coyote.
I don't even want to sound like, hey,
hey, let's see if we do something.
Then I started whistling at him,
you know, not in like a sexual way.
I'm not a creep. I was whistling
of that monkey was domesticated.
I just want to see if I could fuck
them up, you know, just don't come.
You come here,
can we boy.
And the thing was looking at me like,
dude, are you serious? And I was like, no,
not really. I just want to see what
you would do. You fucking cunt.
And then I drove home and I had some
Salami and some horseradish cheddar cheese
and uh, oh, you know what I got the
other day, I got this new Sam Adams.
Um, I really am a Douche bag
this week I'm wearing pajamas,
I'm drinking Sam Adams.
Um,
if I have a story that involves me
having a sandwich with an olive in it,
you guys should really just unsubscribed
to my podcast at this point.
Or maybe any story when I'm standing
here in a blazer with a pipe. Um,
yeah, I bought this new Sam
Adams Beer, like, uh, you know,
they have like the seasonal ones. What
is it that the blackberry something beer.
I know it sounds gross, right?
That's what I was thinking. I'm like,
that sounds gross. I'm
like, but it's Sam Adams.
Somehow they make this shit tastes good.
That Sherry Week Cherry wheat
was something that bears,
I drank and I thought it was the
most delicious beer I ever had.
And by the third one I felt like I
had eaten a whole bag of candy and um,
I was like, I need to stop. But I still
get those. I like to somewhere else.
I think it's fucking,
you know what it was,
I had just seen a Sam Adams commercial
and I fucking challenge you to not want
to go drink 12 beers at the
scene of Sam Adams commercial.
You don't get to see those commercials.
And the guy sticks his fucking face.
And those hops
grabs two big handfuls.
They show how many extra hops they put in,
which I don't even know what does.
Evidently it makes it more tasty.
And then when they put it in that
fucking that beer glass shape shape,
like a voluptuous woman, you know,
and it just looks that perfect color.
That's what was in my head. And I was at
the grocery store, I was like, aw man,
they got a new flavor and that guy's
face in the hops that's very sexual.
Like he's gotta use,
buried his face in some chick's pussy.
And in the end they show her all
filled up and fulfilled, you know,
all filled up and fulfill as
a sentence for you. So anyway,
black berry sweeter the best.
I'm like darker the Berry.
The sweeter the juice they got me.
They all went sex on me
and I fucking bought it.
And I will tell you that was the worst
goddamn tasting beer I've ever had my
fucking life. Okay. You know, I'm
a big fan of these smaller brewers,
even though they're huge. Sam Adams
is huge now, but I'll tell you, Sammy,
you missed the mark on that one.
Cause that tasted like a,
I don't know what it tasted like.
It tasted like Sam Adams
armpit. Okay, that's good.
That didn't even make sense.
Understood this.
Avoid the Sam Adams blackberry. Whatever
the fuck it's called. It's like,
what the fuck was I thinking blackberry?
What the advertisement should that for?
That shit should be, it should be. It's
not a wine cooler. It's not a beer.
Or maybe like it's a bad cop buddy
movie. You know, he's a beer,
he's a wine cooler and together
they tastes like ass. What is it?
I'm actually in my refrigerator
right now. The blackberry. Ah,
Jesus. I can't pronounce it
with beer wit B. I. E. R.
Is it some, a fancy German
way of spelling, uh,
whatever fucking word that's supposed
to be. And that's not a word.
There's no space between it.
I didn't want the fuck that is
and yeah,
I feel like I'm in Woodstock right now.
You ever see that thing where they're
like, stay away from the red tabs, man.
I'm telling you.
Stay away from the Black Berry,
Sam Adams with beer. All right?
It's not a good fucking scene.
It's not a good fucking
scene. And yes, Jesus Christ,
that's it. I'm done with that.
Anytime there's any
sort of fruit in a beer,
you gotta be done. Although I
do like, what does that beer,
they put the slice of orange and the,
uh,
I'm just really going to just say one
Douche bag thing about my personality
after another on this podcast.
This is what it is. You know,
if for some reason, one of you finds
me to be your hero and you, uh,
took out the CD cover and taped
it on the ceiling above your bed,
you know, I just realized I don't
have a poster myself. What kind of,
what kind of fucking entertainer
am I that I don't have that poster.
You know what I mean? When I'm
standing under the tree, you know,
both hands up on the tree branch above
me with the little sea shell necklace and
my shirt opened down to my name
Sean Cassidy poster a,
that's when you know you made it.
That's when you know you made it.
When you're,
when you're posing for that picture and
nobody around you is telling you it's a
bad idea, that's when you know
you made it. That's when you know,
because you have making
so much fucking money.
People are afraid to tell you that
maybe you shouldn't be sitting on a tire
swing with one leg in the air,
you know,
for the poster of your
upcoming tour. Um, okay.
That was a long way to go to do a
Shaun Cassidy reference. Um, anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast and uh,
if you are new to my page
of my website or my myspace page,
um,
welcome.
I did one of these every single Monday.
And people send me a list of questions
of Co Weston's not questions,
questions, because it is the internet. Um,
they send me lists of questions and I,
uh,
try to answer them to
the best of my ability.
I fucking pajamas are killing me. I'm
fucking up with my brain. I don't know.
I gotta let my brain this week, Clint,
my fucking brain. What am I freaking,
I'm freaking out about something right
now and I can't even figure out what the
fuck it is. Um, but anyways,
I do this podcast every single week.
Yeah. They send me questions, questions,
and they, uh, send me their list of
underrated, overrated things. They, uh,
give me movie reviews. They asked me for
advice. They tell me to go fuck myself.
Every once in awhile,
someone such a concert,
they become douche bag
of the week and a in.
Lately people have been sending
me stories about revenge. Um,
which I find fascinating because
that's one of the few evils that I've,
uh,
I've actually resisted.
I have not partaked in,
um oh before I get too deep into this
podcast and we'll let you guys know that
my, uh, my standup special,
why do I do this evidently is on demand.
So,
uh, if you want to have
a little party, you know,
get out your little fucking tea cups and
a table that's way too big for you to
be sitting at. Cause that's what
you do at a tea party though. Yeah.
Does anybody over the age of
five have a fucking tea party?
So they do that over in England or do
they just have fucking tea and just sit
there and stare out of
the clouds? Um, all right,
let's get on with the podcast.
Okay. That was my opening.
Just burst of energy trying to make
this fucking thing funny because, uh,
I only got five hours sleep last
night. Ah, poor fucking baby.
You only got five hours sleep and now
what are you gonna do with the lay around
the next day, the rest of the
day and you fucking pajamas.
You know what about me and the fucking
work and man Trican boilermakers till in
the morning.
Now I'm operating heavy machinery.
Go Fuck Yourself. It's not
my fault. Okay. Fuck you.
You're doing heavy machinery that makes
you make when like fucking 30 bucks an
hour, 30 bucks an hour to take
down a mountain. All right.
That made no sense. What's
so fucking ever, um,
I just have a bunch of random notes here.
Notes that I've made over the past week.
Here's an idea. I had it. An airport,
nothing suffers like the
luggage of fat people.
And I don't know how I came up with that.
I know what it was.
I just saw this woman dragging her
wheelie sideways. Or was it a guy?
I can't remember.
Once you get to that size,
does it really matter if you think
about that? It's become so big.
You'd just come asexual, this is my,
uh, late night DJ voice, sort of,
uh, trying to convince you with some
things. Um, all right. That was creepy.
I'm sorry. All right, let's, do
you want to talk about creepy?
Let's talk about how Obama,
uh, President Obama, oh, uh,
Barack Obama was on the
tonight show this week.
Did that disturb anyone as a
fucking American? Is he in dude,
where's my car part too?
You know,
what the fuck are you doing on the
tonight show? I got a big idea,
my girlfriend about that,
and I said, ah, it's good.
It's a great way to reach people.
It's like,
why don't you ever fucking
press conference, right?
I gotta do is we'll at that podium, the
whole world sits around and watches it.
I'm like, I couldn't, I couldn't,
I couldn't sit there and watch it.
You know what I mean? I, it's like, dude,
shouldn't you be like near the red phone?
What is the red phone rings?
And you're on there, you know,
picking your fucking
march madness brackets.
It's unreal how the presidency of has
just gone downhill just over the last
fucking 10 years.
Like right around 10 years ago was when
Bill Clinton got impeached because of
some fucking Skank,
you know,
every president.
Can you,
can you even begin to understand not only
the amount of world leaders that have
been in the Oval Office,
but the amount of fucking skanks
that have been in there that does the
original playboy mansion. All right,
guys have been in there getting blown
fo for centuries.
Women love power guys love blow jobs.
Okay?
And when you marry the two,
you get the fucking Oval Office
that is ground zero for that shit.
And the guy got fucking impeached for it.
It's right there.
I thought that knocked down in the
presidency that the president with fucking
secret service at his fingertips
can't get a fucking blow job. Right?
He gets busted. And then you
had a, what's his face, uh,
uh, Georgie part to whose dad evidently
didn't teach them how to give a speech.
So we had to look at that fucking
retard for the last eight years,
given a speech where he sounds like
somebody's given a book report who didn't
read the book.
You know what I mean?
Kind of fucking looking around like he
had that shit and now we got this fuck
head going on the tonight show.
Yeah.
Like he's Ashton Kutcher. I
don't know. I don't like it.
This is three, three presidents in a row
where I, I don't like what they're doing.
He wear the blue suit. You wear
the fucking tie and uh, you,
you should have an air about you that you,
and he just shouldn't be on the
tonight show. You know what I mean?
So then this night show Perez Hilton,
Ashton Kutcher it,
President Obama. You know
what? I didn't even watch it.
I'm like literally criticizing. I had
something I didn't even watch. You know,
I just couldn't sit there
and watch that showing.
[inaudible] did you get through and the
president [inaudible] Hani, Hani, Hani,
Hani, he's doing donuts.
We do it very notes.
Um, I don't know. All right, let's,
let's get on. What the fuck? I'm really,
really in an extra fucking
shit mood right now. You know,
it all started last night when I
yelled at that coyote, you know,
that's what I did. I turned my
back on nature and actually kind,
Kinda freaked me out cause it was
just a couple of blocks down my, uh,
oh my street. You know what I
mean? It's like kill a sudden.
It's like a fucking will
Smith movie playing out at
three in the morning. And uh,
I was kinda wondering like where
the fuck that thing came from?
I know the Hollywood hills, that kind
of off there in the distance, but uh,
you know what a coyote eat road runners,
huh?
Who watches cartoons? I do,
but they never catch them.
What does that even fucking true?
You know what I mean? Roadrunners can
fly, right? They just choose not to.
They'd rent a room. They'd rather
run, be the fucking martyr.
Make all the other birds feel guilty
for taking the easy way up. All right,
let's get on with the
questions here because this
podcast is in a culdesac right
now.
I have driven down the street.
It says not a through way and I continued
down the fucking street and now I'm
just driving around in a
fucking circle. Okay. Uh, Bill.
All right. They're listening to your
podcast since I watched you perform.
And because it's nice to hear someone
use the word count every five minutes.
You know, a lot of people have
been giving me shit about that.
Say I used the word count too much
and that they're starting to use it in
everyday life and their uh,
you know,
they're dropping it and weird
times. All right. I'm sorry.
I'm going to try to take, I'm going to
try not to use the word cunt so much.
All right. You can't. Hey, he
did a cunt joke. All right.
In addition is the rest of the
rest of the question about, um,
how do you feel about non Irish,
the way non Irish People Saint
Patrick's Day? Quite frankly,
it pisses me off. It's a day to
celebrate the patron saint of Ireland,
not to get drunk.
I'm from Cleveland,
Ohio and here we have a big
parade downtown. It's so
annoying seeing the drunks,
filling the streets.
People stereotype us as if we're
the only culture that has a drink.
Once in awhile.
I'm Irish American and I'm probably
the only woman of Irish descent who has
never been drunk.
Really.
My family and I usually have a traditional
meal of boiled potatoes, carrots,
cabbage, corn, beef and Irish soda.
Bread. Now, let me tell you something.
If ever there was a fucking
reason to get drunk,
it's the kill, the taste,
boiled potatoes, carrots,
cabbage, corn, beef.
And you can just taste the hot water on
the fucking over boiled vegetables on.
Every nutrient is just taken out of them.
You wonder why as Irish people have such
pasty fucking skin and no pigment of
the boil on the fucking nutrition out
of the, out of the vegetables anyways.
Personally, she says, I think
traditional Irish food sucks.
And it's mostly because they didn't
cultivate much except for potatoes and
cabbage. Well, you ever think maybe they
were too fucking drunk to get a cookbook,
you know,
but I do like Irish soda bread.
I remember you saying you
don't go out drinking. I don't,
I don't think I ever said that.
Is that a Typo? Um, but you,
but do you ever do anything?
And do you like Irish foods?
Um, I gotta admit I really do like a corn
beef sandwich and I really do like the
[inaudible].
I do not like boiled potatoes.
Boiled potatoes are disgusting and you
need at least half a stick of butter,
salt and pepper to just kill
the taste of what you did to it.
You know what I mean?
I'm trying to think of anything that you
should boil other than drinking water
during a fucking catastrophe.
You know,
what do you boil rice?
All right then what you boil.
I Dunno, but let me get back to the
question. How do I feel about people, uh,
who celebrate same faxing. I don't go
out on Saint Patrick's Day. That's a, a,
it's a very bad day to go drinking.
You know,
everybody out in their green plastic hats
and they'd say, Hey, can he navigate or,
and long neck goose.
Yeah. It's, it's very, um,
uh, it's, you know, it's like
drinking on New Year's Eve, you know,
and all the dumb conser out with their
stupid little Corey outfits and is,
if the sound of the noise makers
weren't ear piercing enough,
you got them shrieking over them. It's
just a horrible time to go out. And,
um,
I still have inserted the question,
how do I feel about non Irish people
celebrating Saint Patrick's Day?
I really could give a shit. I
think it's a statement of, uh,
I dunno how empty their lives are or how
the herd just follows whatever the fuck
they supposed to do.
You know,
there's always like that one traditional
guy and he's got to weigh the Sculley
cap in the Irish sweater,
standing over in the corner,
cutting into a bar of soap with a
knife. You know that guy. Um, yeah,
I could give a,
I'm a,
I'm German Irish and I could give
a shit about a Saint Patrick's day.
I don't know the story of
the patron saint and um,
yeah, I don't give a fuck. I think in
the, in the, when I was in my twenties,
I used to go out to pubs
on Saint Patrick's Day. Um,
and I used to do it because
I would thought I could
get laid that night because
I look so Irish. And then
some girl did like, oh my God,
this is what the day is about.
Here's a Leprechaun right here.
Maybe I'll blow them.
That's the only reason why I went up.
I was desperately trying
to be interesting,
but now I just,
I don't go out.
I don't go out on new years and I
don't go out on a St Patrick's Day.
I don't go out on flag day and he
sorta day Earth Day I stay home.
But those, those are, those
are just douche bag days.
And what you want to do is
whatever people are doing is you,
you do it the next day,
like Valentine's Day,
everyone brings their brought out
to go fucking whatever, right?
You can't get a reservation anywhere.
The fucking prices are jacked up
through the roof. This is what you'd do.
You'd go out on the
15th that's what you do.
And you tell you woman that that's what
you're doing because you're gonna get a
fucking table anyway you want. You're
not going to get raped on the charges.
You probably actually to be able
to go to a better restaurant
than you would have on the night of the
14th and that's a great like, you know,
you know a Bronx tale,
the lock, the door test.
That's a great way to see if
you're with the cool girl and on,
if she'd let you take her out on the on
on the 15th because it really doesn't
make a fucking difference,
does it? You know,
you're going to get to see if she is an
independent thinker or if she's fucking
stuck in must see TV,
you know,
and it's going to drag you to the Macy
Day fucking Thanksgiving parade one day.
Cause that's what you do.
Everybody else is doing it.
We have to do it.
I need,
it's not that I don't love you and we're
just going to get raped here on the
price.
You know,
you're trying to find a
bargain on Valentine's Day.
Uh, I'm going to be rude bitch.
But you're in the relationship too.
You're not paying for the fucking
meal. How does that work? Exactly.
Exactly. You know what? Now I'm not even
taking you out. We'll go ahead and cry.
Go ahead and cry.
It's not going to work.
This is all fucking fake because you know,
I just exposed you for being selfish.
I ain't like that. No, that
was great. You liked that.
You liked that little little
riff I did there. I always,
when the hypothetical arguments.
Um, okay. Bill, how would,
uh,
how would I go about getting
a personalized autographed
DVD set from you DVD
sets? I don't know where they
were releasing them in a set.
Do I have a trilogy of Dvds
like the Godfather? Um,
how would you go about that? Uh,
you'd come out to one of my shows,
that's what you would
do and you'd buy one.
And I'd stand there and I'd
fucking sign it for you.
And I'd smile like a jackass is,
I waited the excruciating eight seconds
that it takes for a digital camera to
click before the three flash bulbs go.
Some of those disposable cameras,
as bad as they were for the environment,
I imagine how great with those things,
say cheese click and it was over.
Now they fucking got those digital
cameras. They're like, hey,
lan to today and then just sit in there
waiting and waiting with that fucking
smile plastered on your face.
You know,
like that fucking newscaster who goes to
throw it to the other newscaster in the
field and then it doesn't go.
And then you just staring at the entire
state that you're broadcasting to now
off to Mike,
out in Chelmsford.
Okay. Will seem to be having
some technical difficulty.
That's what it's like getting your picture
taken on a fucking digital camera and
you want to even better is when they
accidentally hit video and then you're
standing there with a smile on your face.
Like
you start talking through your
taste as a god. All the Latin Dad,
you gotta hold it down.
You know,
many times that's happened to me after
my shows and they're like, oh my God,
I had it on video.
And those are the times when I wish I
didn't sell shit at the end of my shows.
You know, I like meeting people after
my shows. I definitely like doing that.
But you know, sometimes you feel
like a fucking idiot, you know,
especially when people come up to
you on like, you know, there's,
there's this joke, can you just say pesto
and then we'll take the picture now.
Now I can. Oh my God, you so
grumpy. Shut up. Take the picture.
Um, all right. Anyways,
uh, he said I didn't want,
let me go on with this guy.
He says I'm happy to pay for it and I
have a downloaded copies paid for to my
iPhone,
but I want an autograph one,
so let me know what I need to do to get
one where I had to pay for it. All right.
I'm kind of being a Douche
here, but like, um, you know,
people ask me for like
autographed photos and Shit.
Like I'm Fonzie sometimes and they never,
they like expect me to pay the postage
and all that type of shit and it's just
like, I'm not doing that. Okay. All right.
I, I hang out at the end of my shows.
I take pictures, I autographed,
I do everything but kiss
fucking babies. All right.
I do this podcast every week.
I'm not going to get myself into this
situation where I got to go to the post
office, you know, every fucking, you
know, every other day. All right.
With Manila envelopes. I'm
not doing that Shit, you know,
trying to think of something
to write before I sign.
That's the hardest thing about giving an
autograph. Can you make it out to Susie?
And then I always write Susie and
then I signed my name and I'm like,
then I tried to think what the
right and I'm like, fuck uh,
God bless a Susie.
What's going on?
[inaudible]
AH, Shit. All right. Who complains about
signing autographs? You know what I do.
I do. Um, okay. Uh, okay,
let's go. Let's get on with it.
I'm really sounding like a fucking
Weirdo. I get off complaining like, Oh,
acted like I would see, someone asks
me for a photograph every other day.
I was going to say every 20 minutes and
I'm like, they'll never believe that.
I'll say every other day.
That's not even true.
It's usually like once a month and it's
usually somebody with a fatal disease
and I still don't send it to him because
that's the kind of guy I am. All right.
Also, Bill, let me move on here.
You should really promote the
broadcast. Okay, Bill, you should also,
you should really promote the
podcast for download on iTunes.
That shit is so easy that once you do it,
you had the podcasts on your iPhone and
you can listen to it in the car anywhere
other than in front of a computer.
Well, there you go. Everybody,
you can download it on iTunes. Thank
you sir. You just hyped it for me.
All right,
last week I had a big question about
the difference between hotels and motels
and uh, well first of all,
before I get into this shit,
um, how about those Bruins?
Huh?
Beaten the New Jersey devils.
I got any New Jersey Devil fans out
that you like that little four to one
victory.
I'm just fucking with you.
You guys got a great team and if
you're not watching hockey right now,
I really feel bad for you all you
guys watching March madness and uh,
you know,
waiting for that,
that awful song at the end
of the tournament when they
show the great moments,
I had a dream.
They usually pick up Lincoln was syrupy
song as they show all the dunks in slow
motion and the people being
excited and then crying.
What is this song that they sing tonight?
I need you.
Oh,
[inaudible]
Tony Right now it playoff hockey is
coming. The flyers of playing great.
The range is lost yesterday,
but they're coming on the
capitols of fucking ridiculous.
The goddamn Devil's got an insane
team as always. I really hate,
I really hate the devils.
I just hate their, uh,
I hate that the country style of hockey
that they played throughout the 90s with
the left wing lock in the trap defense.
I swear to God, not disrespecting,
you know, Marty her over there and the
big records that he got, but you know,
it's a little padded.
It's a little fucking pattern
with the fucking trap defense.
I mean he spent half
his career have to save.
He made with skating behind his neck,
stopping the puck because they just
would dump it in because they clog up the
neutral zone and you know what I mean?
And that was also during the clutch
and grab era. Jesus Christ. I could've,
I could've squeezed out a couple of shout
outs. All right, that's bullshit. I just,
I just hated that period of hockey. And
when I think about that period of hockey,
I think about the New Jersey devils
and I don't still to this day,
I don't understand why the NHL just
didn't say that's an illegal defense.
You know what I mean?
It's like when will Chamberlain was
fucking dunking on everybody. You know,
they came up with rules to,
to keep it competitive because
it's a fucking business. You know,
the three second rule,
you can't have some guy just standing in
the fucking paint who's nine feet tall.
Goaltending they came up with that shit
and they came up with the legal defenses
. I still don't know why
they allow that defense.
It's the worst fuck they had to get rid
of. The red line because of that shit.
I don't know, but I was watching
yesterday and they don't play it anymore,
so I really enjoyed it.
But as usual,
they just got great fucking players
and they play smart fucking hockey.
And uh, I dunno. I Dunno what's
gonna be a tough fucking road.
And uh, for those of you who
are, who don't want to know,
this is a question I have for you little
fuck are these people who are trying to
get the fighting out of hockey? I
don't understand them. You know,
watch a different sport. Hockey
is not for you. All right?
And if it's somebody in
hockey stopped doing it,
don't get rid of fighting and hockey.
All right?
And think that you're going
to be as popular as baseball,
basketball or football.
You're not all right.
You're a rogue fucking sport.
You don't really is hard about
hockey's if you never grew,
if you didn't grow up playing it or in
like a hockey family or in a hockey town,
it's one of the hardest
fucking game to watch on TV.
I was kind of noticing that yesterday.
Like you literally have to be not
only watching what's on the screen,
but what is like literally 20
feet to the left of your screen.
You know what I mean?
You've got to,
you've got to figure out like
a guests when they're like,
you can after a while
you watch it long enough.
You know what's going on to the
left or to the right of the play.
That is literally off the
TV screen. You just, Oh,
the change in lines like you
just know shit like that.
I can't see the puck. Well fucking
watch bowling. You blind bastard.
All right. It was a question I
had last week. Someone I asked,
what's the difference between a hotel
in a motel? You know what I mean?
And I thought it was basically,
you know,
if your door opens up out to the
parking lot, that is a fucking motel.
It's a serial killer.
Doesn't have to kill somebody at a front
desk and get in an elevator or at least
walk a hundred yards of
carpet before he kills you.
That is a hotel now that is a motel.
I'm sorry if he has to do that shit that
is a hotel and evidently I am right.
Because one person said that I was,
and that's the amount of research that
I do with everything in my life. Bell,
if you drive up to your room,
uh,
you are at a motel and use as you deserve
to hear the people fucking next to
you. Oh wait, I read that wrong because
I have dyslexia. Let me start over again.
Take a deep breath focused.
You can do this bill.
If you drive up to your room,
you are at a motel and you deserve to
hear the fucking people next to you talk
about their free fucking Hbo. Okay. That
was really funny and I butchered it.
Um, anyways, he goes,
uh, that shit sucks also.
You're killing me. You're fucking killing
me. You spent $89 on a cheap motel.
Are you fucking nuts? I always hear about
this internet stuff and I never do it.
And he writes in capital letters.
Then he goes back to regular typing.
Listen to me,
go to Priceline.
Next time you're traveling and look up
a hotel and pick the highest star rating
and do not bid any more than 89 bucks and
you'll get the best hotel in this city
for that price.
I would tell you to go
down to 59 or 69 bucks,
but just stick with 89 bucks.
Please just try it once.
I travel the road for 14 years and I
kicked myself in the ass when I realized
what I'd been missing out on.
Thanks for the free podcast are the
highlight of my Monday mornings. Well,
thanks for the fucking Info.
That's that William Shatner. Shit.
I never even,
I don't even pay attention to commercials.
I just look at the fucking,
the glitzy lights. I'm like,
oh wow. Look at, well shit.
William Shatner, you know,
he's keeping it going.
I did star trek 40 fucking years ago
and he's still working, you know,
um, and he has a hell of it to pay.
All right, ask bill. Here we go.
Here's the gas bill. A section of the
podcast that I just started there.
I was all right. Ask Bill.
Bill. I need your advice.
I had something very horrible happened
to me and Oh man, this is brutal.
Settle into your fucking, you're a
staples office chair for this one.
People. This is, this is a
tough situation. All right,
and I don't know if I get the uh, life
experience to get you out of this one.
Um, as bill. Okay, Bill, I need
your advice. I had something very,
very horrible happen to me and
it's nobody's fault but mine.
Nobody's fault but mine, Ben in and Nnn,
sorry, led Zepplin. All right, have this,
I have this friend who don't
get me wrong, is a good friend,
but is that one type of
friend who's really fucking
annoying but wanting to hang
out 24,
seven.
Just recently I got a new girlfriend
and I've been spending all my time with
her.
My friend Ben became jealous,
becoming more and more annoying by making
me feel bad for being with my girl.
Anyway,
long story short to vent,
I wrote an email to my girl just trashing
my friend up and down the fucking road
for being the moron.
Wait a minute.
Could you use a smaller type set?
You know,
I suck at reading a book,
Isaac trashing my friend up and down,
but being the moron that I am,
and here we go,
people instead of just sending it,
emailing it to her,
I checked the send all options,
sending this horrendous email
to everyone on my email list.
Oops. My email list doesn't
really have too many people on it,
but it does have the friend I was
trashing. Of course, it just made,
it just made me realize that you shouldn't
say things behind someone's back if
he can't say it to their face.
So I'm nominating myself for
Douche bag of the week. Lol.
What would be your advice?
Send an apology email or just ignore them.
Uh, that's the worst. That's the worst.
Because you know what
sucks about that is you,
you're 100% in the right that
this guy is a douche bag,
but now you became the
Douche bag because a,
and you know what's funny
is if he had a girlfriend,
he would be doing the same thing.
He just wouldn't have been a
dumb enough to fucking send,
hit send to everyone.
Uh, I dunno. What should you do?
Should you send an apology email? No.
First of all, stop writing things
down on paper. That's number one.
Don't ever do that. And number two, learn
how to spell apology. There was no e
I wouldn't just ignore him.
You gotta take it like a man.
You just got to walk up to him
and just be like, yeah, you know,
I wrote it and you know what I meant that
you've been a con and a and that's it.
So you want to punch me in
the face knowing that I'm
going to defend myself and
punch you too. So you know, that's kind
of where we're at. I know it sucks.
I don't know. You know what I think, uh,
I'm getting uncomfortable thinking
about the situation you put yourself in.
I really don't know what to tell you. I
don't know what to do with that one. Uh,
you got caught and you're fucking,
you kind of turned yourself in.
You should be on America's dumbest
Shit Talkers Llc.
You know, you know that show, right?
America's dumbest criminals and the
guy's put whipped cream on their face and
they stand in line at the bank and it
melts off their face by the time they get
up. This is what this guy, he
did the email equivalent of that.
I don't know what you got to do.
I would just,
I the laugh, I have no idea. You know
what? I got no advice on this one. I got,
I got, I gotta spell this
to the listeners. All right.
I gotta go to way, uh,
what do they say that you got
to, I got a phone, a friend here.
If anybody has any advices what to, what
the fuck this guy supposed to do? Um,
I'll read it next week because I don't
know what to do. You've, you've, uh,
it's checkmate. Checkmate.
Uh, I dunno what to do.
Dump your girlfriend, change your
name and moved to Alaska. Um,
either that or he had just, uh,
I think you just got to take it.
All right. So what did you learn?
No more fucking emails.
Right?
And you've got to watch out too cause
you'll vent to you fucking girlfriends.
And even,
even when she's in a good mood,
she's still going to tell
half the fucking story to uh,
to one of her close friends. You know
what I mean? I Dunno why they just stay.
They really, um, I don't really
think women oh bad to keeping it.
He didn't guys are overrated,
but their ability to keep a secret.
I'm going to keep it a secret
because I forget shit cause I'm,
I have any sort of code. I just, you know,
I have really bad memory and after
like three days, I can't remember.
Like you could literally be like,
Bill,
anyone don't say anything but I fucked
so and so's wife. I feel like shit,
I can't believe it. I have so much
guilt. I just had to tell somebody,
please don't tell anybody. And I'd be
like, yeah, okay. Yeah Dude, no problem.
No problem. And literally, I'm
not saying two, three days later,
but by a year and a half,
if I went out to dinner with
all the people involved,
maybe sometime around dessert, I
would be like, oh, wait a minute.
Wait a minute. He fucked that
guy is who I am. That's right.
That's right. So it's not like
I can keep a secret. I just,
I can't fucking remember. Yeah,
though. We got it. We got it.
And then we understood what the example,
you don't need to go back into it.
Why don't you wrap up the fucking podcast?
All right.
You're 40 fucking minutes
in. I right. Relax.
There's gonna be a long podcast, but
I don't get going here. Um, all right,
let's get onto revenge stories.
Okay. This is a question I have,
because every revenge story
seems to be from guys.
None of them seem to be from females.
So finally,
a woman chimed in with
some sort of revenge,
but it wasn't really revenge.
Um,
or maybe it was revenge and she was just
doing the typical thing that women do
when they tell stories as they never get
to the fucking point. No kidding. Oh,
Jesus. I'm crabby. Tell you. All right
here. Here's one from a hormone bill.
I usually don't take serious
revenge on someone, but I do take,
I take so much pleasure in other
persons fuck ups and misery.
I always take comfort finding out that
someone I hate has such a miserable life.
Here's a story about my egg head
Douche ex boyfriend. All right.
I already liked the sound of this. All
right. To start to start the story.
I will admit that I was a con too.
Rarely. Rarely gave him any sexual,
anything sexual for two years.
Jesus Christ.
That's one of those relationship that
died the final two years and no one,
no one just had the nerve to be like,
hey,
so why don't we both just fuck off
anyways. Uh, she goes at least, uh,
he put up with,
with that shit.
Any other guy would probably want to do
stuff or get sick of it and dump my ass
anyway.
He always played a PC games
such as world of Warcraft.
He got so fucking gross in that game
and paying money every month to renew a
subscription. What a dumb ass, however,
plays can talk to other players in
their guilt or on their side of the,
of the game.
After I broke up with them,
I found out that he was talking to
some chick behind my back for a year.
The story gets better. Um, this is, uh,
this is where my revenge happens.
I don't have to do shit to ruin his life.
I didn't have to do shit to ruin his
life. Okay. So after I dump his ass,
he continues talking to the Conti
meant for them from the game.
He thinks he's in love with
her parentheses, retard.
So we goes to Canada to be
with her where she lives,
I guess he thought she was going
to be the one and he proposed,
but a month later he gets deported
back to America and like a dumb ass.
He lets her keep the $3,000 a ringer on
her finger. After a short period of time,
he tried to go back,
but he gets deported again.
So he's a college dropout who lives at
home with his mommy and he's out three
grand in addition,
while after he starts dating.
Oh, in addition a while after he
starts dating this Jewish bitch,
they were dating for about a year
and a half, one and a half years.
Then she dumps him because
she decides it doesn't,
it's not going to work
out cause he's Catholic.
And the icing on the cake is that all I
have to do to make them feel even more
pathetic is let them find out.
I Bang my boyfriend
and everything he does usually comes back
to me because he keeps in contact with
one of my good friends.
Anyway.
Anyone who is on my bedside who has fucked
with me has always had something come
back to bite them in the ass.
I take great pleasure
in that Jesus Christ.
Wow. That is a fucking,
yeah, Hell hath no fury.
I love how you dumped him and you think
he's a loser and you're still getting
enjoyment that he has this horrific life.
That's scary, man. You know, I usually
expect that sort of evilness out of guys.
You know, and it's just really
frightening. Like that's,
that's a mom that's going
to be somebody's mom. No,
our wire hangers I believe is
another of story of revenge.
Um, you know what it was what that story
you can think of being a jerk to that
person. It's that the guy really
didn't do anything to you. You know,
he was a lame dude.
He was a loser.
You dumped him and then his life
continued to go down the toilet
and I don't know. And you're just enjoying
him getting dizzy as he goes down on,
I don't fucking get it. Anyways.
Um, anyways, here we go. Here we go.
Vent story number two.
About 20 years ago I was living
in downtown Chicago by the way.
This person is like, I know I read really
bad out loud, but this guy is typing,
eat, and even a smaller
type. I don't understand.
Can you guys type a little bit bigger
and don't be a con and just give me the
biggest size. Okay. That's really
a second grade joke. All right.
We're trying to do something serious here.
People do whatever you want.
I don't give a fuck. I'll sit here and
start it through the emails bill. Okay,
let me get out my magnifying glass.
About 20 years ago I was
living in downtown Chicago
and a high rise that had a
multilevel parking garage.
I paid a monthly fee and had
a designated covered spot.
Skye was doing great. It sounded
like you worked like one of those,
fuck oh 20 years ago. I think he was
selling health insurance. Um, anyways,
one night I came home to find another
car parked in my assigned spot and since
it was about 2:00 AM I just said fuck it,
you know,
and drove to the roof deck where there
was always plenty of open spaces.
At about 10:00 AM I was looking out the
window of my apartment and I saw a tow
truck driving down Lasalle Street
with my car attached to the back.
Since I was on the 18th floor, there
was no chance to catch the tow trucks.
So I went down to the office and ask the
manager management why my car was towed.
She said that I was parked
in someone else's spot.
I explained that someone was parked in
my spot and that there was probably 30
empty spots on the roof deck.
Plus the fact that my car had a sticker
on the windshield showed that I was a
resident. She said that there was
nothing she could do and I asked.
So I asked to speak to the
person who had my car towed.
She called the girl who had my car
towed and she came down to the office.
She was a total con about
the whole situation,
insisted that she did the right thing.
Well,
since I couldn't blast
this continent face,
I decided to take revenge on her car
since I knew exactly where she parked.
Once again,
revenge is coming back to fucking
up somebody's car. All right,
so here we go.
Here is their event.
I waited about two months and then I
got a syringe from my mother who was a
diabetic.
Did you make sure she had an extra one?
I hope he didn't take her last one. See,
see what happens when you go down the
road of revenge. Next thing you know,
you stealing syringes from your mom.
So anyways,
I still syringe from my
mom who's a diabetic. Uh,
then I went to a sporting
good store and bought Rut,
which is basically deer urine.
I then proceed to load the syringe
with Rut and I injected it.
I injected it into all the rubber
moldings around the windows of this girls'
cars.
It smelled awful.
My parking spot was one level below her
spot and I could smell it every day.
I know that taking revenge on a car
is a wimpy move, but it did feel good.
Always remember,
revenge is a dish best served cold.
Jesus Christ. Wow, man.
Do you went like fucking CIA on that?
That's like something they
would miss and like the autopsy,
cause it's a little fucking
needle fucking holes. Um,
I got to admit that that is
definitely a, I mean, fucking up.
Somebody's car's not to original,
but at that is
that dude you grew up in the backwoods.
No city kid knows about Rut.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
You grew up in the backwoods.
You did, didn't you? Your mom's a
diabetic, you know, living in a trailer,
ate off of George Foreman Grill.
You're going to show everybody in your
high school class that you will better
than this. She gets some big fancy
job. You live in a high rise.
You had your own spot, you know, and
you will looking out your window,
looking out over the south
street stroke and your cock,
and you thought you had the whole
world by the balls. And what happened?
They told you fucking Mazda Miata right
out of your goddamn spot, right in a,
brought you right back to your childhood,
didn't it?
And then you took revenge the same
way those kids took revenge on you.
And second grade, I don't want to fucking
go with this shit. All right, let's,
let's go to this next one.
Uh, all right, Bill. Uh,
it's just another story of revenge though.
So I did it check for
two years on and off.
And this was my first real girlfriend
in high school and I thought she was the
perfect, most amazing girl in the world.
I was an idiot. And like 17 years old.
I'm still an idiot, 23 but I sure as
hell won't let this crap happen again.
Anyways, I let her walk all over
me and I just took it like a bitch.
It was the kind of thing where she could
fucking cheat on me in front of me and
I believe her. If she told me she wasn't,
I was, I was that fucking pathetic.
Eventually though,
after hearing that your girlfriend
is cheating on you for so long,
it eats away at you.
[inaudible] can you hear the
foreboding music in the background?
Eventually she posted some bullshit
poem on my space, on my space,
about some dudes she was going out with
at the same time she was going out with
me. Wow. That's pretty bold.
And anyway, she goes, the Fucker, uh,
who she was cheating with even had the
balls to post on there talking about how
sweet she was.
So finally I had my proof.
She wasn't getting out of this and
here comes the revenge till I actually
messaged the guy and start telling him
that I've been fucking her the whole time
that he's been going out with her,
he starts telling me that he even knows
of her cheating on him and he took her
back. So we teamed up to destroyer. See,
you see this is, this is, this is where
it goes wrong. This is where it gets evil.
Why do not partake?
They're teaming up now to destroy another
thing and this is how it plays out.
All right, here we go. By this time I was
out of high school and they were both,
and uh,
wait a minute,
but this time I was out of high school
and they were both at the same high
school,
I guess the guy in this girl basically I
showed up to her school and what we did
was bring up all this shit that she
did up in the middle of all her little
fucking friends.
She cared about so much.
She cares so much about and explained
how much of a horseshoe was other dudes
even came up and said they were going
out with her at the same time I was
fucking her and shit.
This bitch was the fucking public bicycle.
Everyone was riding. Will it completely
ruined the rest of high school for now,
five or six years later, me and the
dude are still friends. There's a wind.
There's a wind for the guys who got
treated like shit out there. Yeah,
it is. Yeah. I guess. I don't know, Dude.
That's just fucking, I don't know, man.
I cut my losses.
That reminds me of an intervention story
where there was this girl whose dad
didn't stick around. So,
uh, she, I don't know what,
and she developed young and, uh, the
guys be like, Hey, let me see a titties.
And she just showed them to them,
not realize she just liked
the fucking male attention.
So she's dancing as a cheerleader and
I don't, I don't know what she did.
She blew a couple of guys. And so she's
dancing as a cheerleader in the hope her,
her entire college.
I mean,
high school class just started
chanting whore horror, horror,
horror or something like that.
And then she bursted in tears and
it just became a fucking alcoholic.
You know what I'm saying? But
you know something, you don't,
you don't have the mentality to know that
at that age. And that show wasn't on.
So why am I playing armchair
quarterback and ruin your revenge?
I Dunno. Revenge. Yanno know. I
don't know. Fucking creepy man.
We ruined the rest of high school for and
then we high fived and kicked a puppy.
All right, here we go.
Overrated. Underrated. This
is the last thing here. Um,
overrated. And this is something
that I've been meaning to bring up.
This is one of the I
overrated that I agree with.
I think the most overrated
multi-blade raisers.
A few months ago I started
using my dad's old double,
a double edge razor made almost
20 years ago before I was born.
Born.
It's fucking great.
My face feels better than ever and I can
get a hundred blades for less than what
it costs for an eight pack of those
three or five blade cartridges. Um,
if you've got to shave like a man
introduced an element of danger to it.
I actually have a couple
of straight razors too,
but it's too much work and I
don't use them on a regular basis.
There's not been true this fucking,
one of the worst things that ever
happened to be on the road was I left my
toiletries behind,
I think in Tampa a long time ago.
Not only did I use lose
my little tough crowd, uh,
a shaving kit bag,
I lost that fucking thing.
Um,
and I,
I lost my twin twin blade razor and then
I went onto the triple red blazer and I
have a whisker underneath my nose that it
just can't get, it just doesn't get it.
It sucks around your
chin. It's, it's terrible.
The two blade razor is the shit and you
will never get a closer shave than that.
Everything else is fucking bullshit. I
was wondering though, what about the,
have you seen those things on TV? We
can sharpen your razor blades. Anybody?
I mean, anybody buy one of those? Huh?
Is this podcast going on? Well, my God,
53 minutes. I gotta get Outta here.
Alright. Underrated. Uh, your podcast.
It's fucking great. Thank you
very much. I appreciate that.
Here's another good one.
Overrated chicks and bars and clubs,
underrated chicks at the laundromat.
The skill set in these two groups
is so far off. It's ridiculous.
Chickson bars and clubs just spackle on
so much makeup that they can barely hold
their heads up long enough to accept
your drink before they shoot you down.
But Dude, dramatic pause raising
my eyebrows type shit. Um,
he actually typed up, um, helping me
with my reading ability. I liked that.
I liked direction, but dude, a
chicken, the laundromat is so sexy.
It's crazy. They're wearing probably
the last clean shit that they own.
That's just a little too tight. They don't
meet, they don't put on makeup. So dude,
you're really sounding like a pervert
right now and how they were in that last
piece of clean closet they got.
Yeah, it's a little bit too tight.
Damn.
Put any makeup on?
They're pretty at that moment and
they look unbelievable and you know,
they all look like definite rest of time.
I'm just reading the rest of your
shit like a pervert actually do.
You're actually, you're right.
He makes some great points there.
Plus they're doing some responsible shit
while they're hung over and then trying
not to throw up on their
newly clean clothes. Sorry,
I went too long. He had dude,
you did. You actually make an a great
point. You do. Yeah, you did. All right.
That's the end of the podcast.
Okay. Kind of petered out.
Kind of like the Colorado River,
not reaching the ocean anymore. Um,
anyways,
before I'm going to be in Saint Louis
this week at the house of comedy,
um,
I have the link right there on my website.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com B U R r.com.
And I want to thank everybody
who came out to my Monday shows.
At the punchline in San Francisco.
I really wish I talked about that in
the beginning. Um, the honest with you,
those were two of the best shows I've
ever had in my life. Um, that second show,
W it was ridiculous. Um, for
those of you who weren't there,
I just started telling stories and uh,
I probably did close
to an hour and a half,
15 minutes of which was
actually from my act.
So, uh, you know,
and it was all material I'm never going
to do again because it was all family
stories and fucked up shit that I
would never talk about on TV. So, um,
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I had a great time and I'm thinking about
coming up there again in a couple of
months at the punch line and maybe
having that be a regular thing,
just coming up on Mondays and doing a
couple of shows and just venting about the
people in my life,
you know,
and I'm not having to worry about them
ever hearing about it. All right. And uh,
that is it. Um, thank you
for listening to the podcast.
Thank you guys for contributing
and, uh, what else?
Oh, you know what, I, people have
been asking me about my myspace page.
Ask them about the comments.
Um,
I kind of haven't been adding accepting
comments since last September.
I just kind of forgot about it. I just
was adding friends and answering emails.
I get the podcast took up a lot of times.
So I'm back to accepting comments.
I literally had like 400 or 600
comments that didn't allow me to,
uh, you know, here it is.
Comment approvals, uh, click
on this right now. This is,
this is garbage time right now. You
don't even need to listen to this shit.
I have a 419 that I have to approve a.
So I'm trying to, uh, trying
to get back on that shit.
But anyways,
that's it.
Thank you guys for listening
to the podcast and I'm
going to try to get some new
photos up there on my website and
on the myspace page. That's it.
You guys have a great
week. Okay. Bye. Bye. Okay.